this week is a struggle
[Music]
my problem right now is simply the order
i'm not sure what should be done
after what thing and when i have a list
that i prepared what i need to do that
still needs to be implemented
so i'm not sure what should be done
after which thing and this makes
things problematic because sometimes i
start implementing a thing that without
other thing
wouldn't work and so that's why
i get stuck um and even if i find the
solution
or if i know from react recommendation
how to implement a given thing
how to connect the components how to
make it
display despite all these things
i find the moments when i get stuck
because the order was wrong
just because something else should have
been implemented fast
in order to make this new thing that i'm
implementing working so this
top level logic on the level of pages
and connecting everything with storage
turns out to be the hardest point in
this project
[Music]
[Music]
it is a process and you know the more i
coat
the berry will be added i hope
[Music]
when i get stuck and i don't know what
to do next
with the code which option to implement
what to do
and why i get a bug like that
i reach to these steps i write down the
plan on paper
and i try to write it down with the
smallest steps
so what i should do next uh what
generally should be done what's the
order of these things
at least what i think that the order
should be i talk with other programmers
i consult the things on various forums i
look for
tutorials that have similar projects
i look for tutorials that solve similar
problems
i assertions that overflow or i post on
twitter
or try to look for the solution on
forums and sometimes
i simply take a break from a given
project
from a given problem i try to go to the
next
issue that can be dealt with or i go for
a walk
and you what do you do when you have the
problems with focus
and what to do next in your project
please share your solutions
in the comments below
i want to make each image that is
loaded to the recipe the same size
and to be displayed as cover
so this is another step that i have to
take right now
[Music]
velocity is not a function what
what does it even mean and how to solve
[Music]
it
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to go for a walk or to continue coding
that is a question especially
if you are struggling with some problem
for the last
few hours this is my answer
[Music]
of the ground
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
this project is the example how the
decisions previously made
influence the time needed for the final
implementation
why to give you some examples if i
hadn't decided
to implement images i would save tons
of time you have to resize and crop the
images
in order to allow the users to
add more recipes because local storage
has the limits if not
a user will be able to upload just only
a few
recipes because of the huge photo
but because i believe that images are
crucial when it comes to recipes
and you eat it with your eyes i think
that this is another thing that i will
resign from
another example of how previous
decisions
influence the way influence the time you
have to devote to
implement a project is using materialize
in this project
i used materialize in order to save time
but
right now i'm not sure if i wouldn't
have to deal with
velocity is not a function ever that's
hard to debug
because it is connected with materialize
and with the ui components that i use
from there
[Music]
i want to finish this project as soon as
possible
and make it decent
that's why i want to resign from those
things that i decided that at this stage
they are
too overwhelming for me because they
adapt to
the overall complexity of the project
and they are not in the project
requirements
this way i'm resigning from search
why for example from search well i
wrote down the plan how to implement it
what would be needed in order to do it
and there are many steps that will take
a lot of time right now to finish
that's extra functionality that can be
added later
in some iterations each step
from clicking the search icon to
displaying the result and
going to give a result and later coming
back
to home page or to the result list
everything that
should be referred and designed
and implemented not just only in logic
but also in the ui that would be user
friendly
it's possible but it takes time that i
don't want to devote right now
maybe it's because i'm a bit fed up with
this project and when i really finished
it because it was quite hard
but for the time being search is not
needed
sometimes you have to give up in order
to have the power to come back to the
project
especially if it's not for the client
because if you decided that it should be
designed this way
you can also resign from a given point
at a given iteration
it's sunday in the evening this is how
it looks now
i can add a recipe
add a photo
add the ingredients
some instructions
and save the recipe automatically it is
added to the list
and the list is created alphabetically
so
if it was fries it's after b and before
age and when i come into this
recipe i can edit it or delete it
if i edit it i can
resign from tags add some tags
still i need to fight
with this overlap
this will be the next step i can change
the photo
and save the recipe if a user wants to
delete
a recipe they click delete
and when they reassure this recipe is no
longer in the storage
in the local storage and this fries
recipe is no longer here
so looking at the user stories from
number
one um i can create recipes that have
the names and ingredients yes i can
i can see the index view where the names
of all recipes are visible yes i can
that's the homepage
i can click into any of those recipes to
view it yes i can and then i go to the
detailed view
i can edit the recipes yes i can this is
what we did
and i can delete the recipes yes we
could delete the recipes
all the recipes i add are saved in my
browser's local storage
if i refresh the page these recipes will
still be there
yes it's done if i refresh
there's a disaster here so looking at
these user stories
well they are implemented but
still the app needs a lot of work i mean
it could be better it shows that
fulfilling user stories doesn't mean
that the project is done
next week i'm going to test this project
once again
and to go to smaller js apps
and re-establishing my
js panel js knowledge learning to code
has to do a lot with self-awareness i
think that is also a courage to
experiment
and to choose to try
to take the knowledge from different
sources
having a major plan of course in it like
having the main path that you want to
follow
so i won't go straight away to the next
react uh free code cam project
because i want to work more with
js and stuff for a moment on some
smaller project
or some smaller projects with javascript
to make me stronger in javascript
and to make me think clearer
in javascript this is what i feel that i
need right now
let's check that we will see if it was
the right move keep on doing
remember that learning to code is not a
race
you get your own path your own journey
and take the decisions that you feel
that are good for you at this moment
see you next week
you